hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm John Humphrey so today John and
I I'm gonna check something out oh good
all I read a while ago a couple days ago
our fans petition for a director's cut
of Zack Snyder's Justice League I don't
know exactly what I'm like all right I'm
not surprised but I've had people
actually tweet me this and I haven't
read the petition and I was like okay
let me just see what the paragraph is
and I just scroll through it without
reading anything I was like well this
guy went into some details here so I
thought we can read it together John and
I could decide whether or not we want to
sign this petition I really love Justice
League already as it is so I think
extended cut would be cool absolutely
and the idea of a Zack Snyder cut also
sounds appealing I mean this sounds more
like I am upset with Justice League and
I want to sign the petition yeah I want
to like contribute to that side and that
emotion I would love to read what what
they have to say
it's from Roberto Mota to Warner
Brothers we the undersigned petition
have Warner Bros released the original
director's cut of Zack Saunders Justice
League to the dismay of many the film
that was released by WB was not the film
fans were expecting after a
heartbreaking family tragedy Zack Snyder
stepped down from the film and Joss
Whedon was brought in to finish
post-production this was an
understandable move at the time his fans
were assured by Warner Brothers
president Toby Emmerich that Whedon will
follow the vision that Zack has set okay
well you seem like you've changed pretty
okay directing is minimal and as to
adhere to the style and tone and the
template that Zacks set we're not
introducing any new characters it's the
same character and some new scenes the
course has already been set by Zack only
a few weeks after the statement Joss
Whedon fired junkie XL as the composer
of the Justice League score and hired
Danny Elfman this was once again a red
flag for fans while Danny Elfman is
nothing short of a Ledge in the industry
it was perplexing to make the change
when Zack first st. Joe's junkie XL to
score soon after that reports came that
Zack Snyder had screamed to cut of
Justice League to WB before his
departure and it was decided that some
changes were required while fans
expected we didn't would add some of his
style to the script no one expected the
overall that was ended up being done to
the exact original film and his
Cristeros original script has anyone
seen that that's a rush you know what
what who's cut yeah yeah you know Joss
Whedon's fingerprints are all over this
but how do we know whose is what and how
do we know what wasn't gonna already be
course-correction tone correction all
that stuff a few weeks before the film
released fans were sure to another red
flag was nonsense Justice League was
going to be under two hours a mandate
forced by WB on the film to appeal to a
wider audience those familiar with the
production of the film and style of Zack
Snyder found this troubling Zack Snyder
as a filmmaker is known for longer
grandiose that have a wider message
speaking to our society justice Lee was
originally supposed to be a two-part
film was reduced to one early in the
script stages nonetheless fan still
expected a singular Justice League film
that the consistency of length of Man of
Steel in Batman V Superman a two-hour
film has to juggle multiple goals and
not seem realistic and now the film has
been released this has been a near
universal criticism one would assume
that WB learned from their mistakes when
Batman V Superman was under service by
its editing when many issues were solved
in the director's cut that is a great
point people complained about BBS's
runtime being two and a half hours the
extended cut allowed it to be more
fleshed out and a lot more people liked
BBS after they saw the extent ago I met
up countless people have said once they
saw the extended cut they suddenly liked
BBS so it's really less about runtime
it's more about what you do with the
time given oh yeah it's always how you
use your time and Batman V Superman is
the theatrical cut has a lot of parts
that aren't very intelligible and and
come off as feeling shockingly
amateurish so yeah I do get that one
yeah it does seem like oh you you cut
everything that you could yeah you know
and then some and WB probably should
have listened to the positive response
from the extended cut and decided
against we have to make this under two
hours yeah I feel like they're trying to
rein in too many things yeah but Justice
League haven't been officially released
the films were met with a dismay of
critics fans and most importantly the
alienation of its original fanbase which
is that that was a that's a great point
because when I saw the film I was
thinking I love it but then I was also
thinking to myself well this is very
different the Man of Steel and B vs
those definitely garnered a fanbase so
this could be a turn-off in terms of
tone especially with a lot of Joss
Whedon's
touch sprinkled throughout it what fans
are treated to in Justice League was a
Zack Snyder film
and not in quality much of the thematic
threat of the previous entries was
severed and Whedon's influence on the
script seemed to hold a greater impact
Ontario this included ill-fitting
innuendos between Wonder Woman in the
flash as well as a disrespectful use of
Lois Lane I don't agree with that Lois
Lane was the best I've ever seen both
characters would have never been treated
such a fashion as Snyder's original cut
I go back and see many of the heartfelt
character developing moments by Snyder
were cut through jarring reshoots and
troubling replacement this can be seen
specifically with the character of
Superman a scene of Clark recognizing
Lois's acceptance of his marriage
proposal was replaced with a moment of
Clark uncharacteristically feeling itchy
okay that's a solid point that's that is
a solid point because that's very
different the shot raised in the farm
Murray said I had that Justice League
trailer where you see Clark and the farm
he's like oh you're wearing it or
something showing that she's wearing the
ring people were looking it's a dream
sequence and then you see the movie like
oh that scenes there but it got trimmed
down and it became like I feel itchy
coming back to life that's all got
trimmed down to when that was probably a
more effective moment overall in terms
of heartfelt and drama whatever Superman
seemed to have completely shifted in
Whedon three shoots this is evidenced by
the poorly done CGI to his mustache and
180 shift and personality all this
clearly evidence is that most of Zacks
footage of Superman was rashad this is a
blatant change or the countless fans
across the globe were personally
connected with this Superman in his
struggles Zacks Superman specifically
connected with immigrants and
marginalized groups in Man of Steel I'll
give that to you yeah yes I want part of
the problem with this whole argument
from the beginning one of the biggest
parts of the argument is who is Zack
Snyder's Superman and I've heard people
on both sides of the aisle kind of
complain that it seems like what you
really want to be making is Batman yeah
yeah and for the first time in Justice
League I felt like Superman had some
extra dimensions justified some of the
journey and getting there and made him
feel actually like a Superman who had
gone through an origin and and finally
react his origin was complete yeah like
shifting them in from darkness into
light admired the hell out of it
Superman was like my favorite yes movie
I can see his point though I can see his
point if you connected to that Superman
somehow then I get it there have been
multiple quotes by Zack where he makes
clear Superman is on a natural
progression to becoming lighter after
was a purpose of his trilogy since 2000
sort of teens man of steel fans are
expecting a lighter and more optimistic
Superman and were greeted with a grossly
accelerated version of the kal-el we
feel zack snyder's footage and dialogue
of superman needs to be restored to keep
a level of realistic gross
didn't really bother me you know it was
it was a little bit like shift but at
the same time like he's dead he probably
appreciates live come on just let him
have it yeah it's kind of how I felt
that's a hard one to discuss cuz there's
just so many angles you can approach it
from and so many versions of yeah
opinion about Superman yeah I mean I
give you that maybe it's a bit rushed
and there is something about Justice
League itself where with the hype and
the stuff behind the previous films you
feel like there's an element of like I'm
pretty forgiving that he turns around
really fast because thank God this is a
Superman I actually want to watch him
yeah you know and there's a lot of
forgiving that kind of stuff with this
movie leaked scenes have shown that the
butchering of signers original cut
threads through every cast member that's
very true
III mean it does feel like it was really
pared down well there's there's a lot of
evidence I I saw as I there's so much
footage I remembered scene from earlier
trailers that's cut out of the movie I
saw the other day like 10 minutes
assembled from a combination of trailers
and behind the scenes we were like yeah
like 10 solid minutes they even cut out
like Willem Dafoe's character which I
see here he mentions and there's a lot
of cyborgs they cut out there's a lot of
orange and they cut out which you know
maybe two and a half hours would have
compensated it's not a sniper's cyborg
had a chunk of development or race which
is quite disrespectful when you realize
this was a rare moment to have a person
of color as the heart of a multi-million
dollar blockbuster characters like
Willem Dafoe's volcko and Kiersey
Clemons iris what iris West that's right
iris West was in this it's Flash's girl
we're completely cut from the film that
would have successfully developed and
expanded the worlds of Aquaman in the
flash making the more three-dimensional
heroes rather than a rush final product
and the actual cut I feel like I'm paper
if this with what we saw on screen was
just that in the script it might have
been a little too dimensional but I feel
like the actors made it 3-dimensional
even Aquaman I felt he made it
three-dimensional and oh yeah the
characters is they exist in the
theatrical cut of the movie have very
little to them and the actors bring so
Mike the actors and the the quips they
got Rick
during all the personnel yeah actively
to they bring the three-dimensional to
life there so maybe on paper I'll give
you that and honestly this is I really
feel like a lot of this argument is less
about what Whedon did and more about the
runtime like I feel like the runtime had
the biggest factor into this because you
give Joss Whedon post and he's being
mean told ya yeah it's two hours like
you want me to take a three-hour cut it
turn into two hours yeah that's hard
like that's a lot that's a lot so it's a
like putting a lot of the blame oh look
what we didn't do to Snyder's cut like
that's not fair one again it like we
touched on in our review it seems like
WB has taken kind of every opinion at
100% value and so we have to make
everything lighter we have to make
everything shorter we have to you know
reshoot all this stuff I feel like some
finesse might have helped yes I'll take
a two-and-a-half-hour Justice League if
just a couple other projects cuz it's
not yet two-and-a-half-hour movie
doesn't equal bad automatic yeah much of
the Snyder is visually stunning imagery
was trimmed to fit the mandated to our
runtime with the ancient battle sequence
in parts of Superman's return finally
the change in score was a disappointing
endeavor to preface these calm preface
these comments Danny Elfman's work is
great throughout his career what was
deemed troubling by the fan base was the
lack of thematic consistency well that's
that ECU problem well the music though
is very big I think here's a point he
has a good point no it has a distinct
especially going back to BBS that was
one of the more distinctive yeah it
stood out matters do I say positive so
listen to the Man of Steel Superman song
I still listen to that right over at the
gym today Jogi XL plan to create themes
for every member of the Justice League
while implanting the word Hans Zimmer
used in both Man of Steel and Batman V
Superman oh that would have been cool
themes for every character yeah would be
ready everybody got their own as this is
a growing universe fans expect Hans
iconic score
Superman score to be used for his return
they expected junkies batman-themed and
Hans Wonder Woman theme to be used
regularly well it would have been find a
pepper and original themes of William
Superman it should have been superseded
by Hans theme for Snyder's Superman all
this can be prepared repair about Warner
Brothers by releasing a director's cut
that adheres the Zack centers original
tone envisioned Chris Terrio stripping
junkie XL stone I mean when you put it
like that that one sentence Zack
Snyder's original tone of vision Chris
Terrio screamin junkie
cells tone i imagine you got a very
different film i imagine like a
three-hour cut of just that and the
music especially you got a very
different film as explained above
recommend that warner burgers lisa
directors kozak snyder is just a song
for homeless release restores the
cutscenes and original vision that zach
had for the film much like Richard
Donner had done for Superman 2 and the
Batman V Superman cut it is a
responsibility to WB to right their
wrongs and do well by the fans this is
simply a matter of integrity this is
simply a matter of integrity Zacks on
her left the film that he put the better
half of a decade working towards because
of a tragedy fans were sure by
executives and producers alike that we
didn't edition will only be to service
and complete Sanders vision ended up
being disrespectful overhaul and attempt
to pander to the widest audience as the
box office and critical reception has
shown pandering to the masses is not a
sound strategy and the greatest stories
are the ones told with conviction well
yeah but you gotta have a your previous
movie has to have done well too there is
that to the box of because word of mouth
will not help this but they also have a
bad lead into this I think that there
are a lot of good points in this for
sure and I think that there are some
that are kind of problematic and short
short-sighted I would love to hear the
score I would love to hear the score and
I and honestly I don't have a hatred
toward Justice League the the virgin we
got at all I feel like this is not
likely especially because this movie is
not performing there yeah that was gonna
cost them a pretty good chunk change
your a film that is underperforming at
the box office right now when there's
only so much you can do to study yeah
you can only try and fix things so many
so much has been cut and also I don't
feel like Zack Snyder's version is
exactly humorless when we saw the
trailers a releases a trailer at the
first Comic Con you know that there was
plenty of scenes you could tell when you
watch Justice League which scenes are
reshoots that's an unfortunate part when
you watch it you could especially tell
by Ben Affleck hahaha when he's a little
chunkier his puffy he's bloated and his
hair styled a little different the scene
where the flasher he throws the Batarang
that is was acts Nider and then when he
goes to the car that's joss whedon shoot
yeah you can just tell hair and he's a
more bloated and you could always tell
by that I would be very curious I would
love to see this version I honestly
would love to see that I'd be down
for like an epic tale more origin
different music and an overall different
vibe that doesn't seem like it's
completely void of life like BBS how I
felt personally about BBS was a little
more void of life and the first trailers
you see for BBS I'm for Justice League
before Whedon ever stepped in there was
plenty of life to be had in the trailer
so if you have a combination of Zack
Snyder epic touches with the music plus
you know more intensity and epicness cuz
even the whole scene with Superman when
he first shows up you see images of that
in the trailer
early trailers and that's shot in the
night that's all dark and then when you
see the movie oh it's all daylight now
everything which I liked I liked it but
I would be in in credit so you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna sign this only because I
would like to see the cut not out of a I
feel disrespected I'm disappointed with
Justice League but only because I would
like to see this version of the cut I
don't think I don't think it's actually
ever gonna happen I mean I feel like
honestly I'll give you this I had no
interest in checking out the BBS
extended cut I was like even if this
movie makes sense and works as a
coherent film now I don't want to I know
what the tone in the experience is like
I don't want to do that again I have no
interest however seeing Justice League
one of my complaints about that movie
was like yeah I feel like this could
have used a little more length in a
little more breathing room and stuff
like that so yeah this is a movie where
especially given the behind the scenes
traumas that happen I would be curious
to see what a more unified what the
intended version was supposed to be
because it's also what have been Zack
Snyder's chance as well to take some
criticism and to adjust to it one of the
things about this movie that I didn't
like so much is that it does kind of
feel like a medley of scenes and it
feels like it's in a rushed yeah
somewhere a little bit and doesn't feel
that way to me the second time I watch
it it doesn't feel that way I think it's
much better the second time I watched it
I feel like a lot of flaws I found the
first time I don't really feel there's
still a few things that I would have
absolutely like here you get more
Aquaman's origin and the Zack Snyder
it's like if you cut out an hour there's
a lot more breathe it sounds like they
filled that with scenes instead of a lot
of slow-mo Zack Snyder shots they fill
that with a lot of scenes and I would
have fleshed it out and had it flow
better and you got new characters to
introduce you yeah you need that you do
need it and it's Justice League so I'll
be I've to me the idea of scene a three
hour cut who sounds like freaking
awesome
I would love to see that I would
absolutely I'm totally on board to see
that so two and a half so I'm signing
this because not because I hate Justice
League the cut that's out and I heard
Zack Snyder supporting this petition too
which makes me go Zack Snyder must fuel
his versions very different like in this
may be Zack Snyder feels like yeah this
theatrical cut is not what I had in mind
yeah I don't feel like Joss Whedon and
Zack Snyder are very similar
now makers in any regard and and yeah
with this in a way I am bit curious to
see you yeah Fona compare them what it
was supposed to yeah because yeah like
the big problem with all these DC movies
is that it seems like Warner Brothers
just can't sit down they're always
grabbing it and doing stuff with it
except for maybe Wonder Woman it's clear
that that is not work did you guys sign
the petition what do you think of this
are you gonna do you guys think that we
should all sign this petition and get
the word out on it I personally think
that ID while I disagree with some
points while I do agree with certain
aspects overall I'm in support of seeing
this cut don't think Warner Brothers
will actually do it but if this changes
their mind that would be fantastic I
would totally get my blu-ray purchase
for sure subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification bell you can
follow us on social media download and
follow the star dust a false at the real
rejects 30-second reactions from a film
TV show or trailer and become a patron
eject today oh yeah
Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving